first of all congratulations apple music
has selected you as their up next artist
for
march how does that feel it's crazy
i mean it's it's definitely an honor to
be working with the company like apple
i've seen all these interviews since
like i was young so it's been
i've been watching all these all my
idols be doing this up next
documentary and um it's it's really
crazy that i'm there
one for march you know speaking of past
recipients billy eilish megan b stallion
i mean just to have your name
in the same sentence as these super
talented ladies i mean
do you kind of have a sense of like okay
i'm i think i'm doing the right thing
here
it doesn't click in my head ever it's
really cool it's like crazy
but i mean those billy and megan the
sally
like come on that's some some crazy
company
um but it's it's definitely really cool
do they just call you like like what was
that moment like for you the moment you
heard it
i got a text from my team and we have
like a group chat
and yeah no tight announcement
and they all like it's so funny there's
like three dudes and they're like my
managers
and they'll get all dorky when they get
on the phone and have a big announcement
really you say it you say it it was it
was really cool
oh that's awesome i know your parents
have been super supportive of your
career what was their reaction like
um i mean i firstly didn't really know
what it was
yeah guys this is a big deal
we should be celebrating
okay then i'm gonna assume they have
maybe a bigger reaction when you
appeared on jimmy fallon and jimmy
kimmel
oh yeah i mean yeah it was
it was really cool i mean jimmy fallon
we've been watching for forever same
with kimmel
so a late night show was like it was a
big deal for us
that was really awesome that's so
awesome you know
when you're putting out new music um you
know you're on these late night
shows apple music's calling you you know
be someone to watch
is there a bit of pressure then when it
comes out to putting new music for you
um i definitely think there is a
pressure but not from anyone else mostly
just from me
sitting in my room every day yeah like
you need to do more
um which i i mean which is probably the
worst part because i'm like my biggest
critic
but uh you know i think we're pretty on
top of
releasing things and i've been writing
every single day so
i've definitely been working a lot wow
that's amazing okay so how do you
describe this ep
um so the cp is
i'm really excited for um it's called
too young to be sad
and it basically has like a collection
of songs that kind of revolve around you
broke me first
um kind of just like fit that vibe um
but i've been like sitting on some of
these songs for a really long time and
i just needed to release them as soon as
possible because i've been sitting on
them for so long and
soon i'll get bored it's not like we got
to put these out
yeah you know when you say you're
writing every day was it tricky choosing
the songs you wanted to have featured on
this ep
yeah so originally i thought i was going
to release this ep in the summer at some
point
um but you know so many things ended up
happening
over the pandemic which started messing
up our schedule in a great way
obviously in a really good way but
we had to push the cp back and i kept on
writing songs and then knocking them out
so it kept on getting replaced by better
songs which obviously
i think is a good thing but was a
time-consuming process
yeah you know even though you obviously
have seemed to
be very busy during this pendant i'm
like you know rapel for the pandemic you
were go go go and then of course
we're all told we have to stay home so
how did that affect you kind of
spiritually and creatively
um it was hard because i just got off my
first headlining tour
in january um and so i was in new york
in march at some point and they
literally just
out of nowhere sent us home um and you
know that initial feeling
your stomach drops and you think that
the world is ending
and i mean i think everyone thought that
but then again
i really did think that like my career
would be like ah for the next
how many months is gonna like be put at
a halt
um and so i was really excited when you
know our team we got back and we're like
day one we started working again because
i think i would have gone crazy if i
couldn't have done anything
yeah you know you it's so interesting
looking at your career
you have been professionally trained in
dancing you did that for
years and singing songwriting you know
was there a moment for you where you
realized
like your songwriting and your singing
like you can actually do this this is a
career like was there a moment where
you're like okay yeah this is what i
want to do um
you know i think i always thought i was
gonna be a dancer when i grew up
yeah i really did like that's what i
thought that i was gonna end up doing
until i realized that writing was just
like such a huge
outlet for me um and then as soon as i
started posting on my youtube and
getting
obviously feedback and you know people
expressing that they feel the exact same
way
made me feel like my brain wasn't so you
know isolated from the rest of the world
it's like we all think
same you know you know i think that's
that's how i started to get a grasp on
my writing was
thinking that my stories weren't so
personal to me that like every other
person could feel the same way in their
own life
um and then i just started writing all
the time
and then once you feel that obviously
people people love it i think
you want to keep releasing it and
putting it out there yeah you know you
said that songwriting is one of the only
ways that you can truly communicate your
feelings so when it comes to creating
music and lyrics is there anything
that's
you know off limits for you um
off limits i mean i think there's some
topics that are a little more sensitive
than others
like i just i'm awful at speaking about
myself
which is really weird because i write
about my feelings all the time
yeah um and i think that's because it's
like my only option is
i get really really worked up and i feel
like a lot of things build up inside of
me that i have to
write um but no like if you're if you're
in a room with someone
who you just met it's off limits to
definitely talk about something super
deep
yeah because then i get like okay like
super defensive and i mean that's
that's literally just because it's like
a sensitive part and writing is such a
vulnerable process
that people probably don't realize yeah
no no that absolutely makes sense
you know you've had so much success
recently um is there something that's on
like a bucket list for you something you
would
love to do within the next year or two
um
i mean i i keep on saying i i i did my
first award show
this summer which was like crazy uh
crazy um i just i want to do one in real
life
i want to do one where i can actually go
on stage and do it
i think that would be really cool and
actually meet people meet other artists
yeah that would be amazing yeah i bet
you have such this huge following so i
can only imagine how much you really
want to actually
see people in person yeah no i that's
definitely going to be crucial
to meet other artists my age um yeah
and then obviously my friends too will
keep me a little sane
yeah um you know when it comes to
your career and you know all the hard
work that you've done this is a tough
industry
a lot of people want to get into this
industry so what advice do you have for
other women
who are seeing your career you know your
journey and maybe people are feeling a
little discouraged
um i think the biggest thing would be
not to doubt yourself
and second guess yourself i mean that's
where i feel like i've written the most
you know
not my not my most honest songs at all
is when i doubt myself and i let other
people influence me
um and you take other people's opinions
over yours
if you have something to say you have
something to say and that's it and you
can't
you can't just think that if someone
gives you one opinion that's negative
that you should throw it all away
um i i think especially as a woman woman
in the industry it's
being confident and being confident to
speak up all the time
i've definitely realized that um
especially
a girl my age 17 i feel like you know
people
doubt you a lot and people will you know
not think that your opinions are as
valid
and they're 100 as valid so if you if
you really want to do it you should go
for it
that is amazing advice and yeah i mean
being your age too i can only imagine so
yeah good for you
you already sound so confident that's
awesome
all right so are you excited or nervous
for fans to hear this ep oh i get so
nervous
oh yeah i mean the coolest thing is my
fans are like super
accepting of what i do um and like
always
tend to love my stuff but i get really
nervous release days are like my least
favorite day
even though they should be exciting
because you're putting out like such
vulnerable things and such um you know
stories that
you don't know people are gonna agree
with um
and i think it's it's definitely uh it's
simply terrifying
i can only imagine what would you say is
your most vulnerable song on the cp
um i think you broke me first is pretty
pretty vulnerable um i think it's just
my
the whole thing i feel like has a roller
coaster of emotions of what i've gone
through from like age 14 to 17
so there's a lot of different thoughts
in there different
different days i feel like each day each
month i have a different opinion on
things
a different mood my mood changes all the
time so i love that
um what was your parents reaction when
they first for the ep
um they it's so funny because whenever
they get in the car they always list my
music
ah biggest fans ever
no and i think they really love these
songs it's definitely like their
favorites too
as a family which they love so they they
love getting involved and everything
um you know it was really fun watching
the apple music video where they were
talking about you as you know the up
next artist from march and it was so
cute seeing your dad
oh my gosh it's so cute
like why does it like seeing him get
interviewed so
it was like dad before i went i'm like
don't embarrass me
don't because he says a lot and he
talked a lot
just don't say anything weird um i
couldn't watch his interview but
he killed it he was so cute
i thought he was so nice and i love how
he he almost giggled at you
you know trying to do youtube and when
your video went viral he's like yeah i'm
gonna i'm gonna stop talking
well that was the thing about that some
songs he's like brutally honest
my parents will be like really you like
that
i'm like yes i like it
that was like the first song i ever
released they were like you sure you
want to put that out
i don't know and then it goes viral and
then they're like you can do whatever
you want from now on
that's amazing well it was so nice
getting to talk to you congratulations
on all your success i love the ep
even this morning i'm just listening to
all the songs over and over again it's
really good
thank you i really appreciate that yeah
you